Und ihr seid ja auch schon da. Ich habe gerade eben erst auf Play gedrückt in OBS
Was ist denn da los?
Why the peepo happy time, Leute.
Max ans Trinken erinnern. Ja, habe ich gerade gemacht. Passt schon.
So, am Anfang des Streams macht es eigentlich noch. Aber ihr könnt ruhig alle eure Channel Points
wasten. Irgendwo müssten sie ja hin.
So, Leute.
Heute bis 22 Uhr nur streamen. Was heißt heute nur? Es geht bei mir immer nur bis 22 Uhr.
Aber es geht jetzt erst ab 20.15 Uhr los.
Weder das eine noch das andere.
Also.
Ich musste gerade noch mal kurz E-Mails gucken. Da kamen schon wieder sehr weird champige
Sachen als Sponsoranfragen. Ich glaube, wir machen demnächst mal wieder eine Runde. Ich lese euch ein paar Anfragen vor.
Ich finde es immer interessant. Ich meine, ich mache kaum was auf YouTube. Also im Vergleich zu früher. Ja, ich bin hier ein bisschen auf Twitch.
Aber ich kriege trotzdem den Ultra Spam.
Und da ist teilweise so ein Schwachsinn dabei.
Und auch überhaupt kein Spam.
Überhaupt kein Scam.
Hello, we have a business offer for you.
Guck mal, Leute. Hier, übelster Scam.
Hello, we have a business offer for you. We can donate you
2.000 Euro plus Bits monthly.
Und dann soll ich das Geld abheben und ihn wieder zurückbezahlen, darf aber 30 Prozent behalten. Das ist einfach
Geldwäsche. Das ist einfach Anfrage zur Geldwäsche, die du da bekommst per E-Mail. Alter.
Du bekommst, also was man für eine Scheiße als Anfragenteilweise bekommt, Mann.
Oh, ich habe eine E-Mail von EA. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Entweder ist das Fake, Debate, Overrated, Outdated oder es ist wirklich was.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er weiß, wen er da geschrieben hat.
Okay, aber warum nicht? Hätte ich gar keine Schmerzen mit.
Weil ich habe eine Mail von EA bekommen und zwar EA hat einen neuen Community Manager.
Und er möchte sich vorstellen, weil er jetzt die Arbeit übernommen hat von jemand anderem.
Und er freut sich begeisterte Battlefield Content Creator kennenzulernen.
Ich bin mir nicht so richtig, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob er weiß, wen er da angeschrieben hat, ob er meine letzten Battlefield Videos geguckt hat.
Ob er meine letzten Battlefield Videos geguckt hat, ob er meine letzten Battlefield Videos geguckt hat.
Weil die letzten, die wollten von mir nichts mehr wissen, seitdem ich das Video hochgeladen habe.
Oder wie habe ich das Video genannt? Warum Battlefield 2042?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das Video genannt habe. Irgendwie kompletter Reinfall ist oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich habe doch so eine Promotion zum Release von Battlefield 2042 gemacht.
Und nach dem ersten Video habe ich festgestellt, ich habe es ja im Vorfeld, also Corpium mäßig, ich habe ja nicht gedacht, dass das Spiel so kacke ist.
Da habe ich nicht mit gerechnet.
Also habe ich halt schon mal das Ganze zugesagt.
Und das Problem ist gewesen, nachdem ich das erste Video hochgeladen habe mit dieser Battlefield 2042 Cooperation.
Ich kann euch das ja sogar mal zeigen.
Ja, wann ist denn das rausgekommen? So viele Videos habe ich doch da gar nicht.
Hier war es noch nicht raus.
Hier.
Ja, also.
Das hier war mein erstes promotetes Video dazu.
Das war das zweite.
Also danach, indem ich das aufgenommen habe und das Spiel ein bisschen gespielt habe, habe ich festgestellt, das Spiel ist scheiße.
Und dann habe ich noch ein zweites promotetes Video gemacht.
Das war schon komplett lieblos.
Da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Und dann habe ich das Video gemacht.
Der Absturz von Battlefield ist das noch zu retten.
Und danach musste ich noch ein promotetes Video machen.
Und es hat noch nicht mal ein Thumbnail mehr bekommen, das Video.
Weil ich so abgefuckt war von dem Game und hatte überhaupt keinen Bock, diese Videos zu machen.
Ja.
Nun ja.
Und danach haben die nicht mehr mit mir gesprochen, was ich auch verstehen kann.
Ich meine, die wollen halt Geld machen und jemand, der dann aus der Reihe tanzt und keinen Bock hat, das irgendwie abzufeiern, haben die keinen Bock drauf.
Ich habe es vielleicht auch ein bisschen übertrieben in dem Video, aber letztendlich war das meine, wie soll man sagen, meine ehrliche Meinung zu dem Game.
Warum sollte ich mir da irgendwas zusammen faken?
Zumindest finde ich es witzig, dass sie jetzt wieder schreiben.
Wisst ihr ehrlich gesagt, worauf das hindeuten könnte, dass sie jetzt wieder schreiben?
Wisst ihr, worauf das theoretisch hindeuten könnte, dass vielleicht doch nächstes Jahr ein neues Battlefield kommt?
Weil, wenn nächstes Jahr ein Battlefield kommen sollte, dann müssen sie jetzt so langsam aber sicher die Leute ein bisschen vorwärmen.
Und eventuell wollen sie auch mal wieder irgendwelche internen Events machen, um diesmal wirklich zu checken.
Ob das Spiel gut ankommt.
Nicht so wie bei 2042 einfach so davon auszugehen, ja, geiles Game, best Game ever, wir hauen das jetzt raus, alle werden es feiern und dann, ja, war das halt doch nicht so.
RealAgentSmiths, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also vielleicht antworte ich sogar nachher noch drauf und sage, ich bin gerne dabei, euch Battlefield zu influencen.
Und mal gucken, was denn dann so rumkommt.
Also es wird bestimmt nicht einfach von jetzt auf gleich passiert sein, da ist bestimmt irgendwas am Laufen.
Ich frage ihn aber mal, ob er mein Video gesehen hat von damals.
Ob die dann immer noch was machen wollen mit mir.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch die Story überhaupt schon erzählt habe.
Activision hat damals gesagt, dass sie mich gerne auf ein paar Call of Duty Events einladen möchten.
Was hab ich denn im Hals?
Aber das ist nicht möglich, solange ich ein Video oben habe mit dem Titel, Activision hat neuen Tiefpunkt erreicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das Video noch gibt.
Ja, Activision hat neuen Tiefpunkt erreicht, so hieß das Video doch.
Warum wird das nicht gefunden?
Gibt es das Video nicht mehr?
So ist es doch, ja.
Da habe ich ein bisschen abgerantet über Activision und da haben sie gesagt, den Typ laden wir nicht ein, außer er löscht das Video.
Dass das doch eine gängige Praxis ist, sowas zu fordern, habe ich gelernt, als mich NordVPN angeschrieben hat und gesagt hat,
Max, wollen wir nicht eine Promotion machen für NordVPN?
Damals habe ich dem Moritz gesagt, hier, versuch das doch mal klar zu machen.
Und das hat er dann auch.
Und dann habe ich sogar mit NordVPN schon ausgehandelt, was es an Kohle gibt für ein Promotion Video.
Und dann kommt er auf einmal an, dieser NordVPN Typ, und meint, oh Max, ich freue mich, da hat er so komisch geschrieben damals,
ich freue mich sehr über unsere Partnerschaft und irgendwie so bla bla bla.
Aber, damit wir das jetzt letztendlich abschließen können, musst du dieses Video hier löschen.
Da habe ich halt gesagt,
und dann habe ich gesagt,
und dann ist das halt nie zustande gekommen.
Ich meine, ich denke mir so, können die sich nicht, bevor die mir das schreiben,
bevor die mir ein Angebot schicken, bevor ich ihnen darauf antworte, bevor wir uns überhaupt einigen,
nicht vielleicht einen Blick auf meinen Channel werfen und zu gucken, ob sich das überhaupt für sie eignet.
Ich werde doch nicht einfach Videos löschen, nur weil es jetzt NordVPN nicht gefällt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich habe denen sogar angeboten,
ich kann sogar in dem Video, wo wir die Promotion machen, das alte Video thematisieren.
Und die Punkte, die ich für sinnvoll halte bei NordVPN,
die kann ich ja tatsächlich hervorheben, im Vergleich zu den Sachen, die im Video angesprochen wurden.
Da habe ich halt gesagt, ja Pech gehabt, ich lösche bestimmt kein Video.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Also, wenn ich ein Video lösche, dann höchstens, weil ich selbst cringen muss,
wenn ich es nach 5 Jahren angucke und mir überlege, Max, was hast du da für einen Scheiß erzählt.
Oder manche Sachen, die vielleicht nicht, wie soll ich sagen,
die ich vielleicht heute anders sehe und ich mir denke, okay,
war vielleicht nicht so gut überlegt, was ich erzählt habe.
Also, ich habe insgesamt nicht viele Videos gelöscht.
Ich habe vielleicht 10 Videos gelöscht über die ganzen Jahre,
weil irgendein Blödsinn war oder mir das selbst nicht mehr gefallen hat
oder ich es mir selbst nicht anhören konnte.
Ja, das kann durchaus sein, was Leute machen, aber ich mache das nicht.
Du meinst cringige Videos? Oh ja, da gibt es einige noch.
Aber so ist es halt.
Ich meine, wenn man seit über 13 Jahren auf YouTube ist,
oder sagen wir, seit knapp 13 Jahren, sind ja nicht über 13 Jahre.
Wenn man seit knapp 13 Jahren auf YouTube ist,
der wird es sich nicht vermeiden lassen,
dass man das ein oder andere cringige Video mal gemacht hat
oder vielleicht Videos mit Inhalten, die man heute ein bisschen anders sieht
oder Dinge, wo man sich jetzt überlegt, ah gut, die waren doch nicht so gut durchdacht.
Kommt halt vor nach 13 Jahren, kann man nichts dagegen machen.
By the way, wenn wir gerade dabei sind,
ich mache mal kurz meine 4M an und mache eine Runde Package Updates,
weil ich glaube, heute gab es bei Arch Linux wieder jede Menge neuen Packages.
Wisst ihr, eine Sache nervt mich an der neuen Arbeit bzw. am neuen Job.
Und zwar, dass ich immer so kaputt bin abends.
Also wenn ich fertig arbeiten bin, dann meinen Sport mache
und dann setze ich mich noch ein bisschen vor den Rechner.
Ich bin irgendwie so kaputt.
Das liegt aber einfach daran,
weil ich irgendwie noch, wer weiß, wie das in einem Jahr aussieht,
voll motiviert bin, da was zu machen.
Und wenn man was macht, dann ist das anstrengend.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die letzten 3 Monate auf der alten Arbeit
war ich halt nicht so wirklich motiviert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie war es, falls jemand bei euch,
ja, das war auch übelst cringe im Nachhinein,
falls jemand von euch auch mal einen Job gewechselt hat oder ähnliche Situationen hatte,
wart ihr irgendwie, nachdem ihr die Kündigung abgegeben habt,
oder vielleicht könnt ihr euch das auch nur theoretisch überlegen,
vielleicht habt ihr das noch gar nicht gemacht, aber würde mich mal interessieren,
wart ihr noch ab dem Abgabezeitpunkt der Kündigung bis zum Inkrafttreten
irgendwie motiviert, was zu machen?
Also ich habe mir das nicht so schlimm vorgestellt.
Ich habe gedacht, okay, du kündigst da jetzt, fängst dann am 1.4. woanders an
und du machst jetzt halt noch 3 Monate ganz normal weiter.
Aber ohne Scheiß, Leute, seitdem ich wieder angefangen habe im Januar,
also ich habe ja Ende Dezember, kurz vor Weihnachten, das dann alles abgegeben,
ich habe jegliche Motivation verloren gehabt.
Ich musste mich richtig überwinden, dort immer was zu machen.
Du musst Leute einarbeiten.
Ja, musste ich auch, aber ich habe das so gemacht,
ich habe gesagt, ey, wenn ihr was wissen wollt, sagt Bescheid.
Und die Leute sind dann bis teilweise 2-3 Wochen vor Schluss nicht gekommen
und wollten nichts wissen.
Und ich habe mich dann auch überhaupt nicht darum gekümmert,
die Leute freiwillig einzuarbeiten.
Ich habe gesagt, ey, ich stehe euch zur Verfügung, sagt, was Sache ist, bam.
Haben sie ja dann auch gemacht, noch rechtzeitig.
Ups, jetzt habe ich zugemacht, ich noob.
Aber ansonsten habe ich nichts mehr gemacht.
Doch, bei uns hat es tatsächlich ein paar Leute,
mit denen wir viel zusammengearbeitet haben,
zumindest hat es den Eindruck gemacht,
dass die das interessiert hat.
Wir sind dann nochmal rumgelaufen,
so in ein paar Abteilungen bei den Leuten,
mit denen wir öfters was gemacht haben.
Ich habe drei Packungen, wie heißt das jetzt korrekt ausgedrückt,
Zuckerschaum-Süßwaren, drei Kisten gehabt dabei
und die haben wir dann verteilt und haben gesagt,
hier Jungs, das ist unser letzter Tag heute, macht's gut.
Viele haben das auch noch gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Oh, was, du bist jetzt hier?
Viele haben es natürlich auch schon gewusst,
die meisten wussten es schon.
Ja, aber viele waren auch irgendwie überrascht.
Das fand ich nicht schlecht.
Ich finde, das hat sich schon gelohnt,
sich nochmal zu verabschieden, da rumzulaufen.
Genau, ich habe gesagt, macht's gut, CU.
Ich habe beim Rausgehen zum ersten Mal mit jemand gesprochen,
also an meinem letzten Tag, als ich rausgegangen bin
und zum Bahnhof laufen wollte,
habe ich zum ersten Mal mit jemand gesprochen,
den ich seit über zehn Jahren dort gesehen habe täglich.
Weird Champ, wusste ich gar nicht, was ich erzählen soll, Alter.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie sich die Stimme von dem anhört.
Das stimmt, da hast du recht.
Ja, das interessiert am Ende keinen.
Das interessiert am Ende wirklich niemand.
Also die freuen sich, wenn du dich reinhängst nochmal,
aber es wird dir wahrscheinlich nicht gedankt.
Übrigens, ich habe heute etwas Witziges festgestellt.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt kein super krasses Geheimnis,
die meisten von euch werden wahrscheinlich auch Teams benutzen.
Und ich habe heute mal versucht, über unser Teams,
also auf meiner neuen Arbeit,
habe ich mal versucht, Leute zu adden,
von denen ich noch die Adresse wusste,
nicht nur auf der alten Arbeit,
aber ein paar Leute, die ich noch kenne.
Und das hat funktioniert.
Ich konnte externe Leute adden.
Und jetzt habe ich die ganzen Leute,
mit denen ich mich gut verstanden habe auf der alten Arbeit
und noch von anderen Stellen,
habe ich einfach schon bei mir im Teams geaddet.
Und kann man ab und zu mal ein bisschen schreiben.
Zum Beispiel, dass wir morgen Mexikaner Mittagessen gehen müssen
und sowas.
Mir war das gar nicht klar,
dass man mit Teams random Leute adden kann.
Aber ich meine, es ist klar, dass es geht.
Weil ich habe ja auch jede Menge externe Leute geaddet.
Also natürlich muss das funktionieren.
Ich kann hier beim alten Laden arbeiten.
Natürlich.
Natürlich gibt das das.
Ich meine, das ist ein riesengroßer Laden.
Ich habe vorher bei einer Bank gearbeitet
und jetzt bei einer Versicherung.
Das sind beides riesengroße Läden.
Also ich habe gehört,
ich kann es euch ja mal erzählen.
dass Ende letzten Jahres
fast 100 Leute gekündigt haben beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Aber nicht nur IT.
Und dass das wohl eine noch nie dagewesen große Anzahl ist.
Und da könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wenn 100 Leute kündigen konnten
und der Laden immer noch weiter geht,
dann haben die genug.
Wobei so wirklich genug haben sie auch nicht,
weil die Hände ringen,
immer noch Leute suchen und keine finden.
Den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Du meinst, ob wir uns heute Stellenanzeigen angucken wollen oder wie?
Ja, wenn ihr eine habt, die ich mir angucken soll,
schickt los.
Ich habe jetzt eineinhalb Stunden heute nichts geplant.
Wir können nicht immer so High IQ Zeug machen
wie letzten Stream.
Leute, ich muss mal was sagen.
Ich muss jetzt mal uns,
also mich und euch
und uns hier,
ich muss uns mal loben.
Und zwar der letzte Stream,
ich habe mir den nochmal angeguckt nebenbei.
Ich höre mir manchmal ganz gerne Streams von mir an,
so nebenbei.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum,
aber irgendwie finde ich das gut im Hintergrund
manchmal laufen zu haben.
Ich muss sagen,
das war Content mäßig.
Also sieht man auch wenig auf Twitch sowas in der Richtung.
Sieht man auch wenig auf YouTube sowas in der Richtung.
Da waren richtig gute Sachen dabei.
Zum Beispiel das, wie ich das erklärt habe mit SSH.
Und generell, dass das auch funktioniert hat
mit diesem SQL-Proxy und sowas in der Richtung.
Das war richtig Pog.
Ja, ich soll was unter Metadata schreiben.
Habe ich, glaube ich, gestern auch gemacht.
Man muss es auch mal sagen, ja.
Und der Chat,
und das ist das, worauf ich jetzt eigentlich raus will,
der Chat war auch wieder richtig high IQ.
Kein dummes Geschwätze,
sondern man sieht, hier im Chat sind die Experten am Start.
Vielleicht nicht alle.
Chainlaw mal ausgeklammert.
Aber der Rest schon.
Du kannst auch mit Skype usern auf Teams schreiben.
Gibt es wirklich noch Leute, die Skype benutzen?
Moment, Skype?
Kann man das überhaupt noch runterladen?
Moment, das gibt es noch?
Warum sollte sich irgendjemand noch Skype installieren?
Das ist doch bestimmt Teams unter der Haube.
Und Microsoft hat einfach nur Skype dran geschrieben.
Skype?
Also ich habe irgendwie noch einen Skype-Account,
aber mir war nicht bewusst,
dass es noch Leute gibt, die Skype verwenden.
Ob da überhaupt noch Entwickler dran sitzen bei Microsoft?
Äh, ja, ich habe heute auch mit einem Ex-Kollegen geschrieben,
der meinte, sie benutzen auch Skype für Business.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Was macht die Arch-User-Gruppe?
Da sind, glaube ich, nur drei Leute drin
und wird nicht so viel geschrieben.
Aber die gibt es noch.
Wie steuerst du Audio in Arch, Puls-Audio?
Nein, gar nichts.
Einfach nackiges, noch nicht mal ALSA installiert.
Gar nicht.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Audio.
In der VM habe ich noch nicht mal Audio aktiviert.
Wozu auch?
Ich gucke ja da keine Videos oder so drin.
Ansonsten habe ich einfach nur ALSA installiert
und Firefox kann das ohne Puls-Audio direkt.
Ja.
Wenn ich einen kompletten Audio-Server brauchen würde,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich heute
mich ein bisschen mit Pipewire angucken.
Vielleicht auch wieder Puls-Audio.
Letztendlich ist es halt so,
dieses Ding unter Linux,
du kannst es wieder auf 50 verschiedene Arten machen.
Echt? Okay. FeelsBadMan.
Aber wie macht ihr das denn mit externen Dienstleistern, Apos?
Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Wie macht ihr es mit externen Dienstleistern,
wenn ihr mit denen schreibt?
Die bekommen ja nicht einfach einen Unternehmens-Account initial,
wenn du nur mit denen mal für einen Marketing-Talk reden musst.
Wie macht ihr das?
Also es kommt zum Beispiel relativ oft vor,
dass irgendwelche Unternehmen sagen,
ey, wir haben hier was super geiles
und dann sagt irgendeiner bei uns,
oh ja, dann stellt es doch mal vor
und dann muss dann jemand von den Technikern dabei sein
und sich das anhören.
Und die haben ja doch keinen Firmen-Account.
Wie will man das machen?
Ey.
Muss auch sein.
Geht nicht jeden Tag.
Anzeigen-Review.
EFS-Personio.
Warum hat eigentlich noch niemand die Domain
person.io oder sowas?
Wobei, haben wir es bestimmt schon.
Okay.
Ja, das stimmt, das geht.
Du kannst ja bei Teams-Meetings,
kann man ja sogar mit Telefonen joinen,
wenn man da diese Bridge hat.
Stimmt, hast recht.
Ja, du hast recht.
Ja, ja, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Man kann Leute einfach inviten dazu
und im Zweifelsfall können die auch über den Invite-Link
aus einer E-Mail joinen.
Übrigens lustige, lustige, lustige Story.
Aus einem meiner Vorstellungsgespräche.
Klingt jetzt so, als hätte ich so viele gehabt.
Ich hatte genau zwei.
Bei beiden habe ich einen Vertrag bekommen.
Okay, drei.
Aber das andere hat gar nichts ergeben.
Aber bei zwei habe ich einen Vertrag bekommen
und bei einem habe ich abgesagt,
weil es nicht geklappt hat.
War das auch lustig,
die haben mich eingeladen zu einem Teams-Call
und ich mache das immer so.
Ich benutze immer Teams auf zwei Geräten.
Ich benutze Teams im Browser
für gute Audioqualität und Headset
und für die Kamera benutze ich mein iPhone.
Das heißt, ich joine immer mit zwei Geräten gleichzeitig
und das hat denen ihre Teams-Sitzungen
durcheinander gebracht.
Normalerweise, ihr kennt das vielleicht,
ihr kommt in den Meeting-Raum rein
und da steht da,
das Meeting hat noch nicht gestartet,
sie werden dann hinzugefügt
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Dass ich immer aktiv geedet werden muss
von irgendjemand,
der schon in dem Meeting drin ist
und auf einmal joine ich mit dem Handy rein.
Ich habe versucht,
mit dem Desktop-Browser rein zu joinen.
Da kam dann ja,
sie werden in das Meeting hinzugefügt.
Dann joine ich mit dem zweiten Gerät
vom Handy aus rein
und bin dann mit den Teams
zu meinem Vorstellungsgespräch,
bevor irgendjemand anderes drin war.
Und auf einmal kommt die Personalfrau rein
und ist ganz verwundert,
dass da schon jemand drin ist.
Da habe ich halt gewunken und gesagt,
ja, ich bin auch schon da.
Also das geht doch gar nicht,
sie hat doch in Teams eingestellt,
dass sie erst Leute freigeben muss.
Tja, die hat halt nicht mit
kaputtem Teams auf dem Handy gerechnet.
Okay, was?
Auge, Auge!
Das ist viel besser.
Teams war damals so kaputt auf Linux.
Das ist richtig,
aber ich habe es nicht auf Linux verwendet.
Das war auf iOS und auf Windows,
wo ich das benutzt habe.
Es ist trotzdem kaputt gegangen.
Und ich habe jahrelang übrigens Teams benutzt,
im Browser unter Linux.
Und ganz ehrlich,
das ging immer gut.
Wichtig ist es,
im Browser zu benutzen
und nicht die native App im Browser.
Ohne Mist,
ich glaube,
es gab nie den Punkt,
wo ich gesagt habe,
ich kann was nicht machen,
weil ich unter Linux bin.
Ja, ich glaube,
es gibt gar keine native Linux Version mehr,
oder?
Teams Download.
Ich glaube,
es gibt gar kein Teams Desktop mehr für Linux.
Ist doch eh Elektronik.
Ja, aber ich glaube,
sie bieten für Linux nichts mehr an.
Ich glaube,
sie haben etwas Handy gemacht.
Einfach, weil die Kamera und die Bildqualität
viel, viel besser ist.
Echt nicht?
Auf was denn dann?
Ich meine, es ist nach wie vor
eine Webanwendung auf dem Desktop.
Auf was ist es dann?
Edge Webview.
Ja, okay.
Es ist weiterhin eine Webanwendung.
Es mag halt nicht Elektron sein,
es mag Edge Webview 2 sein.
Moment.
Edge Webview 2?
Ist das nicht noch die alte Render Engine?
Oder ist das schon die neue?
Moment, Moment.
Ist das schon die Chrome Engine drunter,
oder ist das noch die alte Edge?
Weil das, wenn es alte Edge drunter wäre,
würde ich es ja überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Warum?
Okay, Webview 2 ist Chrome.
Alles klar.
Na gut.
Okay, ja gut.
Das kann ich jetzt auch nicht machen, oder?
Es ist halt nach wie vor ein Browser
mit wahrscheinlich React.
Ich vermute mal, es ist React.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Teams React ist,
aber Microsoft steht auf React.
Okay, das weiß ich nicht, ob es funktioniert.
Ich habe nur unter X-Screens geshared.
Das hat immer gut funktioniert.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde, ganz ehrlich,
ich finde, Teams
hat sich zurecht irgendwie durchgesetzt.
Das hat schon ein paar nervige Seiten,
aber im Großen und Ganzen,
seid mal ehrlich, Leute.
Ja?
Im Großen und Ganzen ist Teams,
wenn man das mal mit den anderen Sachen vergleicht,
doch echt okay.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich persönlich,
mir wäre Discord für alles einfach am liebsten,
aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist Discord einfach nicht Business Enterprise genug.
Aber von allen diesen ganzen Sachen,
die es da gibt,
ich musste letztens,
letztens wollte uns irgendein Dienstleister was zeigen,
da musste ich Zoom benutzen, Leute.
Ich habe noch nie Zoom benutzt vorher.
Musst du dir schon mal Zoom benutzen?
Das war ja echt komplett Monarch-es, das Ding.
Ich habe nichts gefunden.
Zoom war, das war ganz schlimm.
Das war ganz grausam.
Ja, gut.
Das stimmt wohl, da hast du schon recht.
Dann dürfte ich,
mit dem Argument würde natürlich auch Discord rausfallen,
weil Discord lässt sich ja auch nicht selbst hosten.
Ja, das ist...
Kennt noch jemand Webex?
Kennt das hier noch jemand von früher?
Das benutzt ja heute, glaube ich, keiner mehr.
Kennt noch jemand Webex?
Das war echt grausam früher.
Webex.
Das ist wirklich richtig grausamer Müll.
Ja, gut, Apple benutzt das für Interviews,
wahrscheinlich, weil sie kein Konkurrenz,
kein direktes Konkurrenzprodukt benutzen wollen
und Apple selbst ja nichts zu bieten hat in der Richtung.
Webex, Alter, das ist richtig grausam.
Webex ist voll im Kopf.
Ne, oder?
Ich würde sagen, das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Immer weniger benutzen Webex.
Gut, was Cisco benutzt, wundert mich nicht.
Ein Programm mit B für Konferenzen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ach so, ja, das gibt es.
Das gibt es, das habe ich auch schon mal gehört.
Ist das nicht irgendein Behördending?
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Okay, Chat, also.
Wir hatten die Stellenanzeige gepostet.
Ja.
Pluto Keks.
Okay, dann schauen wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Wie kommt's, warum fragst du?
Willst du dich dort bewerben?
Ist das die Firma, wo du arbeitest,
falls du was dazu sagen willst?
Und übrigens Gratz an denjenigen,
der eben geschrieben hat,
dass er zum Vorstellungsgespräch eingeladen wurde.
Ich habe es komplett übersehen.
Ach, hier doch.
Ach nee, du wurdest nicht eingeladen,
du hast geründigt, oder wie?
Ja, ich hoffe, es gibt jetzt mehr Kohle, Ugi Frosch.
Kohle und bessere Arbeitsbedingungen,
bessere Arbeitsatmosphäre und insgesamt bessere,
einfach besser.
Wie ist Teams so?
Ich finde Teams ganz gut.
Also, ich mag Teams.
Okay, dann schauen wir uns das doch mal kurz an.
Was gibt's denn hier Schönes?
Ich muss mal kurz etwas...
Okay, das machen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht.
Okay, genug.
Das ist nicht Toss.
Das ist ein Gamesoundtrack.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Okay, geben wir uns eine Runde.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Wupp, mag funktionieren im Hintergrund.
Bisschen, bisschen, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Gucken, dass die Lautstärke stimmt.
Nee, also ich habe...
Ich höre schon ewig Heavy Metal
unter allen möglichen Sachen.
Von irgendwelchen
Death-Metal-Geschichten
zu Power-Metal,
zu allen möglichen Dingen.
Aber das höre ich schon lange,
bis lange, lange,
bevor ich die Physiausbildung gemacht habe.
Ich hätte mal wieder Bock auf ein neues Powerwolf-Album.
Ich weiß, viele mögen die nicht,
aber ich mag Powerwolf.
Eines der wenigen Sachen,
die ich tatsächlich
durch Zufall live gesehen habe
die letzten paar Jahre.
Haben die noch ein neues?
Nee, du meinst hier
Memento Mori oder sowas.
Das finde ich auch gut.
Vor allem den einen Song,
den sie über Herr der Ringe drauf haben.
Oder haben die wieder noch ein neues?
Dann kenne ich das noch nicht.
Ach stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
Da haben wir uns auch schon gefragt,
ob das ein Field Engineer ist.
Nee, dann kenne ich das nicht.
Muss ich mal nachher gucken.
Ja, stimmt, ich erinnere mich dran.
Okay, also lass uns mal
jetzt die Stellenanzeige anschauen.
Okay, dann ist er wirklich noch ganz,
ganz neu.
Field Engineer macht doch private Variablen.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
das ist eigentlich viel zu kurz,
viel zu kurz.
Das müsste dann ein
Field Engineer Singleton Manager Factory sein.
Dann macht der vielleicht private Variablen.
Und der macht bestimmt auch IF-Schleifen.
Wir sind uns ja einig,
dass IF-Schleifen prinzipiell das Beste sind.
Leute, die in der Z...
Ach, Field Engineer nennt man das heutzutage.
Ich habe das immer Turnschuh-Admins genannt früher.
War ich ja selbst.
Also die Jahre,
wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
war ich Turnschuh-Admin
und beim neuen Arbeitgeber
so die ersten paar Jahre,
als wir uns noch selbst
das war nicht immer Rechenzentrum,
auch Technikräume und sonst wie.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich habe es euch ja schon 500 Mal
Recycle Story erzählt.
Ich konnte euch anhand der LEDs
im Rechenzentrum morgen sagen,
ob alles okay ist oder nicht.
So sieht das halt aus,
wenn man das jeden Tag sich anschaut.
Okay, also, auf geht's.
Senior Java Entwickler.
By the way, ich habe das Gefühl,
dass mein Mikrofon ein Tick zu leise.
Ich raste aus unter Windows.
Nie finde ich den Button
auf den ersten Blick,
wie man die Input lautscht.
Warum, jetzt mal seriously,
warum kann man hier,
man kann die Output-Lautstärke einstellen,
warum kann ich nicht die Input-Lautstärke
einstellen an dieser Stelle?
Das geht hier irgendwo jetzt.
Ja, nee, passt eigentlich.
Okay, also,
ein Senior Java Entwickler,
Cloud und Plattformen,
männlich-weiß-deutsch,
Musik ist nicht zu laut, oder?
Passt, glaube ich, ganz gut im Hintergrund.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Okay, also,
was haben wir denn Schönes hier zu bieten?
Permanent.
Warum ist das eigentlich auf Englisch?
Und das andere auf Deutsch?
Liegt vielleicht an meinem Browser.
Na gut.
Senior Java Entwickler, Cloud-Plattformen.
Permanente Full-Time München.
Alles klar.
Eine Aufgabe,
die herausfordert.
Legen Sie die richtigen Architekte ...
Wisst ihr eine Sache,
die ich schon mal gut finde an dieser Stellenanzeige?
Besser als bei den meisten anderen Stellenanzeigen?
Oh,
grad Schlucke auf.
So.
Das wird Puls-Audio hinbekommen.
Also, wisst ihr, was ich schon mal sehr,
sehr gut finde an dieser Stellenanzeige?
Dass die nicht anfangen,
mit drei Seiten über sich selbst
zu beräuchern.
Das finde ich immer die langweiligsten Sachen
an allen Stellenanzeigen.
Wenn dann sowas drinsteht,
wir sind die XYZ GmbH,
Marktführer im Bereich,
bla bla bla.
Das ist immer das gleiche
und immer das gleiche doofe Zeug.
Deswegen finde ich das gut.
Einfach nix zu sie schreiben.
Wunderbar.
Wenn sie interessiert, kann ich nachher nachgucken.
Also, eine Aufgabe, die herausfordert.
Das sind die komischen Weichen
für unsere Smart Grid Management Plattform.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt mal sogar nach...
Smart Grid, hat das was mit Strom zu tun?
Oder...
Stromversorgung, ja.
Dachte ich auch jetzt.
Ja, Plattform für Energie.
Was nett.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt Jobs bei Netflix.
Gucken wir uns mal einen Job bei Netflix an.
Level 5.
Die sollten das Five Head nennen.
Dann weiß jeder, was das heißt.
Ja, das ist diese komische Netflix-Struktur,
die nennen das ja nicht direkt irgendwie
Junior, Senior, sonst was.
Die nennen das ja irgendwie
Juniors.
Die haben ja diese L1, L2, L3, L4, L5, L6, L7
und dann gibt es irgendwie noch
noch Staff Engineer
und so komisches Zeug.
So, aber gucken wir uns erst mal das an.
Levels, kannst du das Garten auch schon?
Das wird es erst mal unabhängig davon.
Also für die hier, oder was?
Oder für Netflix?
Ja, das Netflix-Garten
Ja, dass Netflix ordentlich bezahlt,
das bezweifle ich auch gar nicht.
Aber das sind doch eigentlich alles
immer nur Ami-Stellen, oder?
Die sind doch wahrscheinlich
in Deutschland auch ein bisschen
ups, ein bisschen
zurückhaltender.
Ach, die ist in Kalifornien.
Ja gut, dann gibt es
Massive Nice Geld.
Ach hier, hier kannst du dir
diese ganzen Levels angucken, genau hier.
L5, L6, Staff Engineer,
L5, L6, Staff, irgendwas.
Genau, das meine ich.
Ach ne, L4 ist hier quasi sowas.
L4 ist dann sowas im Endeffekt
wie das, was nach Junior kommt.
Also quasi das,
das was man nach dem direkten Einstieg
Okay, aber lass uns erst mal
das hier kurz angucken.
Was wollen wir denn hier?
Weichen für unsere Smart Grid
Management Plattform.
Ja, kann ich mir nicht so
allzu viel darunter vorstellen,
aber wahrscheinlich irgendwas
mit Stromversorgung, okay.
Entwickeln Sie smarte und skalierbare
Microservices, die für stabile Verbindungen
zu unseren Kommunikationsgates
Das ist halt so komplett
generic, so.
Das kann einfach alles sein.
Das sagt halt so gar nichts aus.
Das ist, das ist wie,
wenn ich sagen wir mal
eine Server-Admin-Stelle ausschreibe
und sage,
Remote einloggen auf Betriebssystem
notwendig.
Remote einloggen auf System
notwendig oder sowas.
Dann sagt sie, ja,
wie jetzt, was jetzt, wo jetzt,
warum und warum schreibt ihr das
überhaupt? Okay, Microservices
weil wahrscheinlich Cloud.
Designen und implementieren
Sie durchdachte APIs
für komplexe Marktprozesse.
Okay.
Mit ihrem Know-how tragen Sie
entscheidend zu einer stabilen
und resilienten Plattform
für das Internet der Dinge
in Energienetzen bei.
Okay, hier ist jetzt sogar mal
ein bisschen spezifisches Zeug drin.
Du kümmerst dich wohl um Backends,
um Backend-Geschichten
für IoT-Geräte.
Das klingt gar nicht so,
so uninteressant.
Ja.
Okay.
Ihr Background,
der uns überzeugt.
Erfolg.
Bla, bla, bla.
Mehrjährige Berufssoftwareentwicklung
idealerweise mit
Microservice-Architektur,
Webentwicklung, Java-Ökosystem.
Erfahrung mit Kontainerisierung,
Orchestrierung von Services,
Docker, Kubernetes oder
Kubernetes oder Kubernetes
oder was auch immer.
Grundlegende Erfahrung mit SQL
Man kann in Postgres
sowas schreiben.
Drop database with force.
Das wusste ich bis dahin
gar nicht.
Ich hatte heute nämlich das Problem,
dass ich zu faul war,
die Sachen erst zu uninstallen,
bevor ich was testen konnte
mit Zugriffsberechtigung
in der Datenbank.
Also habe ich einfach
die Datenbank force gelöscht.
Da ging zwar das Service kaputt,
der drauf zugegriffen hat,
aber es war zu erwarten,
weil es war eh nur ein Testservice.
Kenntnis in agiler Softwareentwicklung
in agilen Teams
sowie
Moment,
sowie zugehörigen Tools
wie Jira
und
sowie zugehörigen Tools
wie Jira
Jawoll
Jira
und GitLab
ShitLab
Höchste Qualitätsansprüche
an die eigene Arbeit
gepaart mit der Attitüde
einen möglichst reibungsfreien
DevOps-Betrieb der Plattform
zu ermöglichen.
Das ist alles so
wie umschreibt man das?
Also ich verstehe,
dass es ihrer Meinung nach
in die Richtung geht,
was sie für Leute wollen.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass die, die die Anzeige schreiben,
ja eigentlich schon wissen,
was sie haben wollen
und jemand, der die Anzeige liest,
es aber nicht so wirklich versteht,
was sie sich dabei gedacht haben,
als sie diese Sätze geschrieben haben.
Zumindest geht es mir immer so,
wenn ich das lese.
Das sind so nichtssagende Sätze.
Ja, da stehen ein paar Begriffe drin,
die sich nichts daraus ableiten,
dass ich sagen würde,
oh ja, das ist cool,
das will ich machen
oder da kenne ich mich gut drin aus,
das habe ich schon fünf Jahre gemacht.
Ja, da würde keiner sagen nein.
Also ganz ehrlich,
stellt euch mal vor,
ihr wollt den Job haben
und die fragen euch,
habt ihr höchste Qualitätsansprüche
an eure Arbeit?
Niemand würde sagen,
ah, also jetzt,
ne, ne,
sorry für die Bewerbung,
ich habe nicht höchste Qualitätsansprüche
an meiner eigenen Arbeit.
Das macht doch keiner.
Deswegen kannst du dir das eigentlich sparen.
Ich fände es immer cooler,
sie würden da ein bisschen konkreter
was hinschreiben,
was ihnen eigentlich davor schwebt mit.
Eigenständige Arbeitsweise kombiniert
mit der Leidenschaft für Testbarkeit,
Wartbarkeit,
Beobachtbarkeit.
Da wollte einer unbedingt
und Resilenz in Software,
oder da wollte auch jemand
irgendwie Ausfallsicherheit
und Hochverfügbarkeit vermeiden,
in Softwareprodukten.
Also hier sieht man da schon mal
einen Denkfehler,
weil
Testbarkeit
und Wartbarkeit
ist egal,
wenn man keine Fehler programmiert
und alles first try funktioniert.
Die müssen eindeutig öfters
bei mir in den Stream gucken.
Wie man das macht.
Du brauchst keine Doku,
du brauchst keine Tests
und du brauchst keine Kommentare
in deinem Sourcecode.
Du musst einfach immer nur
fehlerfrei programmieren.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Überlegt mal, wie viel Geld man damit spart.
Ich sollte mal irgendein Buch schreiben
Fehlerfrei Driven Programming.
Einfach immer first try
alles perfekt programmieren
und man hat keine Probleme mehr.
So einfach ist es.
Mit reiner Softwareentwicklung
ist das nochmal anders, wie jetzt.
Willst du etwa sagen,
irgendwas, was ich im Stream
schon mal programmiert hatte,
hätte nicht first try funktioniert.
Fake News, Alter.
Weird Champ.
Wieso ist da noch keiner drauf gekommen?
Das liegt daran,
weil die nicht so viel Prime Support
haben wie ich im Chat.
Die können da nicht drauf kommen.
Dazu brauchst du mindestens
300 Prime Subscriptions.
Okay.
Einen Blick in die Energiewirtschaft
und einen Überblick
über die Smart Metering
Moment, was zum?
Niemand hat das.
Niemand, der nicht aus dieser Richtung kommt,
hat ansatzweise Überblick
über Smart Metering
und Smart Metacrit Systemlandschaften.
Keck Maxe.
Dankeschön für den Sub, Pog.
Nice.
Extremly nice.
Aber okay, alles in Ordnung.
Jetzt, auch wenn ich ein bisschen Blödsinn erzählt habe,
liest sich das hier vollkommen in Ordnung.
Werden Sie Teil eines engagierten Teams
und gestalten Sie Ihre und unsere Zukunft mit.
Dafür bieten wir Ihnen
Arbeitsplätze an attraktiven Standorten,
gutes familiäres Betriebsklima,
blablabla, das schreiben Sie alle.
Einfach ist Auslegungssache,
ob das Vor- oder Nachteil ist.
So nach dem Motto,
ey, mach mal hier.
Wir brauchen das in zwei Monaten.
Wie du das machst, ist dein Problem.
Ist vielleicht auch nicht so geil.
Also ist immer die Frage, wie das ausgelegt wird.
Leistungsgerechte Bezahlung.
Tja, dann lass doch mal eine Zahl springen.
Individuell weiter mobiles Arbeiten.
Okay, ja, das ist gut,
dass Sie das da unten drunter geschrieben haben,
weil das interessiert eigentlich keinen.
Ja, ist keine schlechte Anzeige.
Ist halt sehr 0815
und wird wahrscheinlich nicht dazu führen,
dass Sie jemanden finden.
Es sticht zu wenig raus
und ist zu wenig aussagekräftig
und auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise
zu langweilig gestaltet, geschrieben.
Also mich würde es jetzt nicht ansprechen.
Aber gut, ich bin auch kein Java-Entwickler.
Chat, ich weiß,
wir haben einige Java-Entwickler
beziehungsweise Leute, die das ansprechen könnten.
Was sagt ihr?
Also ich finde es sehr 0815 und irgendwie langweilig.
Also ich würde mich da wahrscheinlich nicht bewerben.
Wenn ich noch andere Sachen zur Auswahl habe.
Wenn ich sonst nichts zur Auswahl habe,
warum nicht?
Das macht einen ganz normalen Eindruck.
Jetzt weder besonders gut noch besonders schlecht.
Was ich ganz cool fand,
was ich ganz interessant fand, war das hier.
Weil ihr wisst ja,
ich interessiere mich auch sehr für IoT-Geschichten.
Allerdings die restlichen Sachen passen da nicht.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt klar, worauf Sie raus wollen.
Es geht um smarte Stromzähler und so Dinger.
Genau, das hätte mich auch mal interessiert.
Was Sie da genau machen.
Es ist nicht eine Sache gefallen.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was gefallen ist,
ist Docker und Kubernetes.
Aber das ist jetzt nun wirklich nichts Besonderes
in der aktuellen Zeit mehr,
dass man mal was von Docker oder Kubernetes
zumindest gehört haben soll
und vielleicht mal die ein oder anderen Sachen
da mal ausprobiert hat.
Das ist jetzt wirklich nichts weltbewegendes,
wo man sagt,
oh, damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Aber das ist doch für dich egal,
wenn du Backend-Entwicklung davon machst.
Du machst irgendwelche Java-Backend-Entwicklung
für ihre Smartmeter.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das in Wirklichkeit so einen großen Unterschied macht,
ob das jetzt Stromzähler sind oder smarte Klübien.
Die nutzen garantiert Selbstgebautes.
Aber so manche...
Ach so, GitLab stand, glaube ich, auch irgendwo noch drin, oder?
Ja, GitLab und Jira.
Das ist jetzt aber auch nichts Besonderes.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich,
die werden nicht alles selbst gebaut haben.
Zum Beispiel Springboot ist ja so der Shit schlechthin.
Jeder benutzt Springboot.
Chat, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Ich benutze kein Springboot,
weil ich bin kein Java-Programmierer,
aber Springboot ist voll der Shit in der Java-Community.
Das finden die alle geil.
Und ich habe mir das mal erklären lassen
von einem Java-Entwickler von ein paar Jahren.
Ich habe ihn gefragt,
warum benutzen alle mittlerweile Springboot anstatt Tomcat?
Und wisst ihr, was seine Antwort darauf war?
Vielleicht könnt ihr mir das erklären, Chat.
Seriously, sehr ernst gemeinte Frage jetzt.
Seine Antwort darauf war...
Moment, ich...
Ich denke mir jetzt nichts aus, ne?
Kein Fact.
Ich muss es nur mal kurz richtig zusammenkriegen,
wie er das gesagt hat.
Er hat sinngemäß zumindest sowas gesagt wie,
Tomcat ist ein Anwendungs-Server,
da läuft die...
Ne, genau.
Er hat gesagt, im Tomcat läuft die Anwendung,
in Springboot läuft der Tomcat in der Anwendung.
Und da habe ich dann einfach nur da gesessen
und habe mir gedacht...
Was willst du mir damit sagen?
Und warum ist das jetzt besser?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung hat er auch gesagt,
aber ich verstehe...
Ich check das trotzdem nicht.
Was da...
Ja, aber warum ist das der Grund,
dass ich das benutzen will?
Ist das quasi so wie bei ASP.NET Core zum Beispiel,
dass halt ein Web-Server dabei ist,
dass ich mich freuen kann,
dass ich nicht irgendwie was anderes brauche,
um dann meine Anwendung auszuführen?
Das ist tatsächlich praktisch, ja.
Aber...
Aber das kann ja nicht das Einzige sein.
Ja, na gut.
Du meinst bei Stromzählern?
Ja gut, aber...
Ich meine, wenn du Java-Backendsachen baust
für IoT-Geräte,
da wirst du ja damit nicht allzu viel...
allzu viel zu tun haben, oder?
Wie das wirklich vor Ort aussieht
bei den Geräten.
Du baust ja dann keine IoT-Geräte.
Du baust irgendwelche Backend-Surfaces,
irgendwelche APIs,
irgendwelche Time-Series-Datenbanken
immer, dass du die eingelieferten Daten
verarbeiten kannst.
Du hast ja mit dem eigentlichen Smart-Meter
wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun.
Also so wie sich diese Anzeige gelesen hat,
macht der...
Also es sieht für mich ganz stark nach
so ziemlich reinem Backend aus.
Weil die auch was von Kontainerisierung
und Datenbanken und so schreiben.
Das liest sich sehr Backend-mäßig.
Quarkus ist im...
Okay, Java, Moment.
Wir lassen uns das jetzt mal kurz erklären.
Quarkus.
Supersonic Subatomic Java.
Also eins muss man ja sagen.
Die Sprüche der Framework-Erfinder
werden auch immer besser.
Supersonic Subatomic Java.
Alles klar.
Oder Java, wie das die coolen Leute aussprechen.
Supersonic Super...
Da kann ich mir ja gar nichts drunter vorstellen.
Ups.
Da kann ich mir gar nichts drunter vorstellen.
Creating a first application.
Oh, mein Auge, mein Auge.
Ich seh nix.
Gut.
Igitt, komisches Pompfeil oder was das ist.
Ja, i.
XML, hör mal auf.
Ich kann nicht richtig auf die Seite gucken.
Ich muss die Hand vor die Augen halten.
Das ist zu hell.
Okay, und...
Okay, alles klar.
Quarkus.
Ist das Pog, Leute?
Ist Quarkus Pog?
Stimmt das, was der Captain Poggers hier von sich gibt?
Und dann mit Kotlin oder mit Java?
Was würdet ihr sagen?
Nicht, dass irgendjemand denkt,
ich möchte demnächst Java-Programmierer werden oder so.
Gibt es eigentlich auch Server-Admins,
die es hassen, Java-Anwendungen zu administrieren?
Ja, sicherlich, aber ganz ehrlich.
Also, ich mach mich ja auch immer über Java lustig.
Letztendlich ist Java vollkommen legitime,
also gerade JVM ist schon lange gereift,
vollkommen legitime Business-Enterprise-Backend-Technologie,
die millionenfach verbreitet ist.
Egal, ob ich mich darüber lustig mache oder nicht.
Und definitiv lieber Java als C++, das ist wohl wahr.
Ob ich mich jetzt darüber lustig mache oder nicht,
ist vollkommen unerheblich.
Java ist da und Java taugt auch,
sonst würde nicht so viel damit gemacht werden.
Ja, muss man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen.
Und letztendlich eine Java-Anwendung zu administrieren
oder eine Go-Anwendung oder eine PHP-Anwendung oder sonst was,
ist für einen ordentlichen Admin eigentlich kein großer,
großes Ding.
Und sollte das modern verkontainerisiert sein,
dann macht es eh keinen großen Unterschied.
Hat man noch VMs mit Linux,
wo dann Dependencies installiert werden müssen für Anwendungen
und Pfade angelegt werden,
Permissions richtig gemacht werden
und vielleicht sogar noch Java-Versionen installiert werden müssen
und sowas.
Ja, da muss man schon ein bisschen mehr machen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ein ordentlicher Admin
hat weder mit Java-Anwendungen
noch mit PHP, Go, Python, C-Sharp oder sonstigen Anwendungen
irgendwelche Probleme.
Das Einzige, was Admins nicht mögen,
das kann ich euch sagen,
ihr habt das selbst lange genug gemacht,
sind outdated Anwendungen,
die Probleme haben mit den Sachen,
die das Betriebssystem mitliefert.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn Anwendungen so outdated sind,
dass sie auf neuen OS-Versionen nicht mal laufen.
Aber da kommt meistens auch mittlerweile Containerisierung
to the rescue und dann geht's wieder gescheit.
Spring Boot ist doch viel besser,
da musst du nicht deployen.
Ja, aber Moment,
wie kommt denn die Anwendung sonst auf die Systeme,
wo sie drauf ausgeführt wird und läuft?
Ohne Deployment.
Das Problem ist, dass wenn man Spring dockert,
die Application-Server-Layer nicht mehr gecached werden.
Es gibt die einfach nicht.
Ach so, das heißt im Endeffekt,
der Build vom Container dauert länger
und der Container wird ein bisschen größer.
Ja, so what?
Irgendwem juckt's, oder?
Ich meine, nicht wirklich ein Problem,
wenn das irgendwie 40 MB größer ist, der Container.
Generell finde ich persönlich Containergröße nie ein Problem.
Als wenn das Ding jetzt nicht irgendwie 30 GB groß ist oder so.
Also ob mein Container jetzt 100 oder 300 MB groß ist,
juckt mich nicht.
Oder nur 20.
Ich bin auch von Alpine Linux komplett weg.
Gibt jetzt einfach stinknormale Debian-Container und gut ist.
Ah, ich sehe hier, sind die Java-Fiveheads am Start schon.
Quarkus ist halt cool,
weil der Code benutzt die Java-Enterprise-API.
Und Spring nicht, oder wie?
Wildfly habe ich auch schon mal gelesen irgendwo.
Ja.
Aber spiel denen nichts aus meinem Stream vor.
Das kommt bestimmt nicht so gut an.
Also für mich ist das egal.
Aber für dich wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, weil ich habe mich ja schon so links und rechts
ein bisschen drüber abgelästert.
Nicht, dass es nach hinten losgeht für dich.
Aber du kannst es ja nochmal in...
Oder du klippst irgendwas raus, wenn du was zeigen willst,
was deine Meinung untermauert,
ohne mein blödes Gelaber drumherum.
Ich will nicht, dass...
Also wie gesagt, wegen mir kannst du es machen,
aber ich will nicht, dass es für dich nach hinten losgeht.
Ich mag Java nicht.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Ich hatte auch mal einen Azubi,
der sollte ein Body-Mask-Index-Konsolenprogramm programmieren.
Also so, wisst ihr, so Alter eingeben,
Gewicht eingeben, Größe eingeben und ausrechnen.
So super easy eigentlich.
Und...
Das hat er in C-Sharp gemacht.
Und irgendwann kam er zu mir.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, sogar schon mal erzählt.
Und irgendwann kam er zu mir und meinte...
Also es hat ewig gedauert.
Also jemand, der ein bisschen Programmier-Basics kann,
macht das wahrscheinlich in einer halben Stunde.
Und irgendwann, so nach ein paar Tagen,
kam er zu mir und meinte,
Max, Max, es geht endlich, es geht endlich, es geht endlich.
Und...
Was er damit meinte ist,
nicht etwa die Anwendung funktioniert richtig,
sondern es hat jetzt mal kompiliert.
Er hat einfach so lange copy-pasted,
bis es kompiliert.
Und dann habe ich das Programm gestartet
und dann stand dann im Terminal,
da stand dann im Terminal sowas wie,
bitte Alter eingeben.
Jeder hat mit so einem Programm mal angefangen, ja.
So, und dann habe ich dann eingegeben,
bitte Alter eingeben, habe ich dann eingegeben,
Max und Enter gedrückt.
Bam, ganzes Programm gecrashed.
Nein, nein, du kannst jetzt doch nicht einfach irgendwas eingeben.
Ach ja, das habe ich erzählt, das war der Endpunkt.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ja, dann habe ich das erzählt schon.
Ne.
Ich glaube, das kennt da auch gar keiner.
Hat er das auf Shit-Hub gepusht?
Wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber das ist der gleiche Azubi,
der auch meinte, dass man es Shit ausspricht,
anstatt Skit.
Den habe ich auch mal in einem Video eingegeben.
Ich muss den mal wieder anschreiben,
was er gerade so treibt, Herr Endpunkt.
Okay, haben wir noch irgendwelche Stellenanzeigen,
die ich mir angucken soll?
Ich habe noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Ich bin jetzt so richtig in Fahrt gekommen,
können wir uns heute noch eins, zwei angucken?
Ach so, Netflix.
Netflix wollten wir uns ja angucken.
Was haben die denn zu bieten bei Netflix?
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal was
in Los Gatos, California.
Okay,
Netflix macht das,
wenn wir anfangen,
erst mal Lobeshymne auf sich selbst singen.
Aber, ich meine, es ist Netflix,
wir wollen es ihnen mal nachsehen.
Was bedeutet das L5?
Das ist quasi die Stufe,
das ist sowas wie
Senior-Java-Entwickler,
sowas in der Richtung.
Guck hier, hier siehst du das.
Ja, Senior Engineer,
L5.
Das heißt, da verdienst du schon richtig ordentlich Asche,
vermutlich mal bei Netflix,
als L5.
Wenn man das mal überträgt,
falls man das übertragen kann.
Also ich bin auch L5,
wenn du so willst, bei,
also rein von meinem Jobtitel,
wenn man das hier vergleichen kann,
wobei es bei uns halt nicht L5 heißt,
sondern
halt einfach nur Senior Engineer.
Es kann aber auch sein,
das muss ich auch gleich dazu sagen,
es kann auch sein,
dass es überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ist,
was Netflix unter einem Senior Engineer versteht
und was eine Versicherung in Deutschland
unter einem Senior Engineer versteht.
Also insofern.
Okay, Java machen, die Bayer.
Okay, sie suchen eine neue Verstärkung
für das Bayer-Team
oder Baja oder so.
Sie suchen jemanden, der highly motivated,
oh, da kenne ich jemanden.
Kennt ihr den auch?
Der super agil und highly motivated ist?
Ich, ich, ich,
wie jetzt?
Haben die,
ey,
haben die etwa,
ne, bis vor einem Monat gab es den noch?
Haben die,
ich glaube es ja nicht.
Jemand,
jemand bei LinkedIn eingeloggt
und kann mal nachgucken?
Wie, das gibt es nicht mal im Google Cache?
Der ist nicht im Google Cache.
Alter, was ist das?
Die wichtigste Seite ist nicht im Google Cache.
Ich habe noch nicht mal,
ich habe noch nicht mal ein Account,
also nicht mal den Login mehr für den Account.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube,
okay, also die suchen jemanden
für
ihr Baja-Team.
Microservice-Ecosystem,
okay, sie suchen einen highly motivated
Senior Software Engineer,
der ihnen joint,
um die growing needs im Netflix-Development-Ecosystem
zu supporten.
Alles klar.
Was wollen sie dann haben?
Curious,
Empathic,
ich kann das nicht mal richtig aussprechen,
Innovativ,
alles klar.
Okay, was wollen sie haben?
Man soll neugierig sein,
proaktiv im Suchen und Verstehen
von Feinheiten und Perspektiven,
alles klar.
Ein strong Teamplayer,
own and,
was, was wollen die haben?
Own and drive,
achso, man soll hinterher sein,
ja, wie soll man das übersetzen?
Man soll Verantwortung übernehmen,
sowas in der Richtung, ja,
vom Netflix-Java-Ökosystem,
so sinngemäß.
Java in der Firma voranbringen,
ja, das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
So, immer zu gucken,
alles zu verbessern
und jemand,
der einen strong focus
on developer experience hat.
Ich habe einen mega starken,
strong, strong,
richtig strongen focus
on developer experience.
Das heißt auch,
Entwickler sollten Linux verwenden,
weil sich darunter einfacher entwickeln lässt.
Wisst ihr das,
hat Netflix freie Betriebssystem-Auswahl?
Nicht, dass die ankommen
mit Windows-Notebooks oder sowas.
What do you expect,
what to expect from us?
High impact,
exciting challenges,
great team environment,
must-haves,
alles gut, okay.
Microservice architecture experience,
preferred at scale,
okay, hey,
ich bin zwar kein Java-Dings-Senior-Higher-QL-5-Engineer,
aber das habe ich wenigstens.
Eine Sache hätte ich schon mal, ja.
Experience working with partner
and stakeholder teams on creating solutions,
ja, das habe ich auch,
das habe ich auch,
aber fünf Jahre auf
an industry experience developing in Java
habe ich nicht.
Will ich auch gar nicht.
Large-scale distributed system fundamentals,
ja, damit kenne ich mich auch aus,
damit kenne ich mich auch aus,
damit kenne ich mich auch aus, ja.
Was ist denn IPC?
Wäre gut, wenn man es hat,
oder so, ah ne, hier,
oder Requirements muss sein,
weil hier ist nice to have.
Spring Boot habe ich keine Erfahrung mit,
gRPC Java habe ich auch keine,
Spring Webflux,
ja, die meinen aber doch bestimmt nicht Interprozess-Communication an der Stelle, oder?
Reactive Fundamentals haben doch mit IPC nichts zu tun,
die meinen damit irgendwas anderes.
Webflux,
Webclient,
Solid understanding of what can go wrong in a large-scale network,
oh, damit kenne ich mich aus,
Customer Support Experience,
oh ne, habe ich nicht, will ich auch nicht.
Ja, ganz ehrlich,
die haben da drauf wahrscheinlich eh schon 5000 Bewerbungen,
einfach nur weil es Netflix ist.
Also, aber wer auch immer das vorhin gepostet hat,
applied euch und probiert euer Glück,
wenn ihr da Bock drauf habt.
Netflix hat in Deutschland nichts,
dann müsst ihr halt nach Kalifornien.
Gibt Leute, die haben da bestimmt voll Bock drauf.
Let's go.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt erst,
ich bin jetzt erst in Fahrt gekommen,
ihr könnt mir ruhig noch eins, zwei posten,
halbe Stunde Zeit habe ich noch.
Wow,
aber die Amis,
die verdienen ordentlich Kohle.
Ich meine gut,
die müssen auch mehr bezahlen insgesamt,
aber trotzdem bleibt ihnen noch mehr Geld.
Deko, Dankeschön für den Sub,
habe ich gar nicht gesehen,
POG Subscription,
ich gucke mal, ob ich noch mehr vergessen habe.
Ja, die Amis müssen sich auch selbst versichern,
aber die verdienen so viel mehr,
dass sie trotzdem selbst versichern,
noch mehr Geld haben.
Nee, hab nichts übersehen,
aber Daco, Dankeschön für den Resub.
Ich könnte mir das vorstellen, ja, keine Ahnung.
Bei der Kohle sollte das aber auch so drin sein.
Ja, habe ich nicht nur mitbekommen,
habe ich heute sogar live schon bei mir in Twitter gesehen.
Also,
man konnte es gar nicht,
nicht mitbekommen so.
Du musstest das ja sehen.
Ja, das stimmt schon,
aber dafür verdienen sie eine halbe Million im Jahr
auf der Posi.
Da kannst du ja lange gucken.
Ja, mich persönlich auch,
aber die Kohle ist halt schon sehr nice.
Bei uns auf jeden Fall nicht.
Bei uns kriegen die Entwickler auch wirklich ordentlich Kohle.
Was ist das? Jobs Wien.
DevOps Jobs in Wien.
Let's go.
Heute mal die Österreicher am Start.
Wie viel kriegen die denn bei euch?
Das kommt ein bisschen darauf an, was es ist,
aber Senior Entwickler kriegen bei uns auch,
wobei ich muss sagen,
bevor ich jetzt die Zahl sage,
da sind auch,
da ist Bonus
und eventuelle Wochenendeinsatz
und deployments und so,
falls man die braucht,
ist da alles schon mit dabei,
aber die kriegen auch um die 100k.
Also das ist schon in Ordnung,
was sie denen bezahlen.
Für fünf Tage die Woche.
Und danach geht es sogar richtig krass weiter.
Also wir haben bei uns sogar nicht nur,
also da ist nicht Schluss.
Du kannst auch,
ich habe es gesehen,
der hat denen geholfen.
Was ich cool finde,
ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich es richtig gesagt habe,
dass sich der Auskennt-Fuchs
im Extrem-Pog auskennt mit CSS.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Super, oh Gott,
was ist das?
Moment, die Überschrift reicht schon.
Die Überschrift reicht schon.
In Österreich, Leute.
Ein DevOp-Superhero
WMX
Beko.
Kennt man die?
An alle österreichischen FiveHeads im Chat
die Frage,
Beko,
was geht so?
Es geht gleich bad gear in einer halben Stunde.
Was kriegen die Entwickler?
Auch das weiß ich nicht.
Müssen wir mal schlau machen.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
So, also lasst uns mal gucken.
Beko, Österreicher sind heute mal dran.
Ich glaube Österreicher hatten wir sehr selten
hier in Stellenanzeigen bisher.
Willkommen bei Beko.
Österreich, okay, die machen wieder
das gleiche langweilige wie immer.
Erstmal selbstübertrieben Lob preisen.
Okay.
Willkommen bei Beko.
Österreichs führendem Anbieter,
technischer Dienstleister.
Über 50 Jahre arbeiten wir bla bla bla bla bla bla
mit einem bunten Team aus kreativen Köpfen
und dem gebündelten Know-how
von IT-Spezialistinnen und Experten.
Moment.
Von IT-Spezialistinnen
und Engineering-Expertinnen.
Es soll ja jeder machen,
wenn er Bock drauf hat,
aber es liest sich halt wirklich kacke
an der Stelle, ja.
Denken wir quer weiter und voraus.
Dabei glauben wir vor allem an eins,
Fortschritt in allen Farben.
Ja.
Habt ihr auch schon ein sehr buntes Logo.
Aber wir bei Beko reden nicht nur von der Zukunft,
wir arbeiten daran.
Vielleicht auch schon bald mit Ihnen.
Alles klar.
Wir,
DevOps Superhero WMX,
gestalten die Zukunft in Wien.
Vollzeit ab sofort.
Also, auf geht's.
Bist du bereit?
Denken quer.
Die haben, glaube ich, was verpasst, oder?
War das nicht auch vor kurzem
fast schon eine Beleidigung?
Na gut, in Österreich vielleicht nicht.
Die hatten nicht so viele Querdenker
in Österreich vielleicht.
Ich finde es übrigens super kacke,
dass das Wort querdenken
so negativ behaftet ist mittlerweile.
Für mich hat das früher
eigentlich eher was Positives ausgezeichnet.
Ja, so um die Ecke denken.
So in positiver Art und Weise.
Leider wurde das so negativ besetzt jetzt.
Okay, bist du bereit,
die Welt der Technologie zu revolutionieren?
Ja, Leute,
darunter machen sie nichts.
Die,
also unter revolutionieren geht da schon mal gar nichts.
Du gehst morgens ins Büro,
machst deinen Rechner an,
denkst dir, okay,
was revolutionieren wir heute?
Wir suchen einen echten DevOps Superstar.
Oh, cringe, Alter.
Cringe.
Wir suchen einen echten DevOps Superstar,
der bereit ist,
Dice of,
oh, Dice of Cringe, Leute,
das brauche ich als Emote.
Moment, das fehlt mir jetzt.
Das mache ich mal schnell rein.
Das fehlt mir.
Genau das brauchen wir jetzt.
Äh, sign in.
Hä?
Bin ich eingeloggt?
Wie, ich bin nicht eingeloggt?
Natürlich bin ich eingeloggt.
Boah, fuck, Alter,
jetzt kann ich Dice of Cringe nicht hinzufügen.
Ja, dann lasse ich es halt.
Dice of Cringe wäre jetzt sehr praktisch gewesen, ja.
Egal, ich füge das da im Stream noch hinzu.
Das braucht man öfters.
Okay, also unter revolutionieren machen wir es schon mal gar nicht.
Der bereit ist, die Grenzen des Möglichen zu überschreiten
und gemeinsam mit uns die Zukunft zu gestalten.
Das ist dann so ungefähr wie,
wir hätten gerne ein Rechteck.
Ihr kennt ja bestimmt diesen Sketch auf YouTube,
dieses Video, The Expert oder wie das heißt.
Wir hätten gerne ein Rechteck,
aber es soll an einer Ecke
keine Ahnung, rund sein.
Aber dann ist es kein Rechteck mehr.
Oder wir hätten gerne zwei parallele Geraden,
die sich überschneiden und sowas.
Ja, das ist schön,
dann ist es aber nicht mehr das, was ihr haben wolltet.
Wenn du ein Leidenschaft,
okay, wenn du, was,
wenn du ein Leidenschaft für eine Leidenschaft,
ich will jetzt aber nicht den Rechtschreib-Nazi raushängen lassen.
Wenn du eine Leidenschaft für Code
und eine Vorliebe für das Zusammenbringen von Entwicklung und Betrieb hast,
dann lass uns gemeinsam Großes erreichen.
Okay, ein bisschen viel geflamed,
aber ehrlich gesagt, das ist was, wo ich mich auch sehe bei sowas.
Ja, in solchen Positionen.
Nicht in Wien und auch nicht Vollzeit,
aber das ist prinzipiell für mich gar nicht mal so schlecht wahrscheinlich,
was es hier gibt.
Also, als DevOp Super,
das sind meine Aufgaben, also nicht meine Aufgaben,
also die, wenn man sich bewirbt.
Als DevOp Superhero wirst du unsere technologische Infrastruktur zum Glänzen bringen.
Okay, du wirst die Schaltzentrale sein,
die die Entwicklungsteams und die Betriebsabteilung miteinander verbindet
und eine nahtlose und effiziente Softwareentwicklung zu ermöglichen.
Okay, das ist alles so krass in Superlativen geschrieben,
aber prinzipiell würde ich sagen,
deckt sich das irgendwie mit der Jobbeschreibung,
was die hier unten tippen, ja.
Ich meine, Schaltzentrale als einzelne,
ja, aber ich weiß, was sie meinen.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben geschrieben,
aber ist okay, ja.
Von der Automatisierung der Deployments
bis hin zur Optimierung der Skalierbarkeit
wirst du die treibende Kraft hinter unseren innovativen Projekten sein.
Leute, ich habe so den Eindruck,
man ist der Einzige in dieser Position dann.
Die haben festgestellt,
Mist, bei uns läuft es nicht so rund,
gerade in der Zusammenarbeit zwischen Betrieb und,
also Operating und Entwicklung
und wir schaffen jetzt eine DevOp Stelle
und mit der wird dann alles gut.
Das wird aber so wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren,
wenn beide Seiten denken, sie können weitermachen wie bisher.
Eindeutig zum Boomer für den Job, ja.
Ich hoffe, für Skalierbarkeit denken sie an zwei Sachen.
Erstens, man verwendet keine Cloud-Anbieter mehr,
sondern Hyperscaler, weil es cooler klingt
und zweitens direkt diagonal skalieren.
Stell dir vor,
du stehst vor einem digitalen Universum
voller unendlicher Möglichkeiten.
Alter, übertreibts halt mit Superlativen.
Ist ja gut.
Meine Güte, was kommt denn als nächstes?
Jetzt übertreibts halt voll, Mann.
Mit deinem Wissen über DevOps-Praktiken
und deiner Fähigkeit,
die neuesten Tools und Technologien zu beherrschen,
wirst du die Herausforderungen
des technologischen Fortschritts meistern.
Okay, da kommst du nur nach 15 Satz dahinter.
Wann wird eigentlich die CSS-Lösung
von Auskennfuchs diagonal skaliert bei einem Hyperscaler?
Ich würde sagen,
da brauchen wir erstmal eine weltweit distributed
Cassandra-DB-Installation
und dann mittels Edge-Computing
das CSS aus.
Also wir liefern nicht einfach nur CSS aus,
sondern wir liefern quasi JavaScript aus,
der on the Edge das CSS berechnet
und dann ausliefert,
um das richtig agil zu sein.
Nicht, dass das einfach altes CSS ist.
Das muss frisch generiertes CSS sein.
Nur dann ist das richtig modern und agil.
Genau.
Ich sehe schon,
du musst öfter solche Besprechungen abhalten.
Lass MetaBase touchen,
um das zu besprechen.
Das ist so ein unglaublich dummer Satz.
Den könnte ich mir tatsächlich
in irgendeinem Coaching vorstellen.
Ich würde sagen,
das ist unser gemeinsamer Key zum Success, oder?
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Hier.
Ja, genau.
Lass uns mal backcirkeln.
Wir sollten allerdings auch den Scope
nicht aus den Augen verlieren, oder?
Also,
wisst ihr, was wir mal probieren müssten, Chad?
Wir müssten mal versuchen,
wie lange wir es hinbekommen,
einen Stream zu machen,
wo wir nichts aussagen,
außer irgendwelche bescheuerten
Buzzword-Sätze zu bauen,
die sich so anhören,
als wären es Antworten auf andere Buzzword-Sätze.
Okay, es geht weiter.
Du wirst der Architekt sein,
der die Grundlage für...
Okay, das ist tatsächlich so,
die haben Probleme zwischen Entwicklung
und Operating,
oder zwischen Softwareentwicklung
und Admins,
und denken sie,
ein super DevOps-Typ,
der reißt es jetzt komplett raus.
Man sieht,
da sollen sich die Sachen
komplett ausdenken.
Du wirst der Architekt sein,
der die Grundlage
für eine stabile und agile
Softwareentwicklung legt.
Ja, Moment,
aber...
Du kannst jetzt ja nicht...
Was sollst du denn sonst noch machen?
Sollst du da jetzt auch noch
agile Softwareentwicklung einführen
und die Leute
zu Daily Scrums verhaften?
Du kannst mal Day in the Life
of a Linux-System-Engineer machen.
Bitte korrekt,
ich habe heute gelernt,
das ist wichtig,
wenn man sich mit Netflix-Leuten
vergleichen will,
kann man ja auch
nicht so ein Linux-Engineer machen.
Nee, kann ich nicht machen,
weil ich da zu viel leake.
Ich habe mir das ernsthaft
schon überlegt.
Ich habe wirklich schon drüber
nachgedacht, das Ganze zu machen,
bzw. wie man das machen könnte,
aber ich bin zu keinem
machbaren Schluss gekommen.
Ich würde einfach links und rechts
alles leaken und sehen.
Ich kann ja auch mich nicht zeigen.
Wisst ihr, andere Leute
sagen, hey, ich habe jetzt
hier gleich einen Daily,
filmen sich dabei und blören
den Bildschirm ein bisschen aus.
Kann ich nicht.
Ich kann den Bildschirm nicht
filmen, weil ich was leaken würde
und ich kann mich nicht filmen,
weil ich dann auch was leaken würde.
Ich habe keine Möglichkeit,
solche Videos zu machen.
Und mit jedem Klick
den Weg in eine bessere Zukunft
ebnest.
Meine Güte,
wirst du zum Helden
der kontinuierlichen Integration
und des Deployments.
Du wirst die Teams inspirieren
und motivieren,
die neuesten Best Practices
anzuwenden
und Innovationen voranzutreiben.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft,
was wollen die überhaupt eigentlich?
Was wollen die überhaupt?
Ich check's nicht.
Die ersten zwei Sachen klangen
ja noch irgendwie ganz passend,
aber jetzt wird es langsam einfach
nur so global galaktisch
alles zusammen.
Ich glaube, die wissen auch nicht,
was sie wollen.
Ich glaube ganz ehrlich,
die haben Probleme
in der Abstimmung
zwischen Entwicklung
und Admins.
Und die denken jetzt,
einen DevOp-Typ dazwischen zu setzen
löst alle Probleme,
wird es aber überhaupt nicht.
Null.
Du hast in diesem Jahr keinen Bock mehr.
Du wirst die Teams inspirieren
und motivieren.
Mit deinem Fachwissen
und deiner Entschlossenheit
du bist quasi ein richtiger Enabler,
wie man so schön dazu sagt.
Mit deinem Fachwissen
und deiner Entschlossenheit
wirst du die Effizienz steigern
und uns dabei helfen,
unsere Ziele schneller
und besser zu erreichen.
Profil.
Moment, Moment,
du solltest über fundierte Kenntnisse
und Erfahrungen im Bereich DevOps verfügen.
Einschließlich automatisierter Deployments,
kontinuierlicher Integration
und Cloud Platform.
Okay, da muss ich sagen,
damit kenne ich mich aus,
das habe ich ganz lange gemacht.
Du solltest ein umfassendes Verständnis
der Softwareentwicklung
und der zugrundeliegenden Technologie
Ja, solange es nicht C++ ist,
habe ich das.
Erfahrungen mit Programmiersprachen
wie Python oder Java
können uns nicht einigen.
Ich weiß, das ist immer so
so Nitpicking,
aber das ist immer eine Sache,
die triggert mich genauso wie Ipschleifen.
Können wir uns nicht einfach
darauf einigen,
dass das einfach alles
Programmiersprachen sind?
Ja, früher hätten die Leute geschrieben
Programmiersprachen wie Java
und Scriptingsprachen wie Python.
Können wir uns nicht einfach
darauf einigen,
es sind alles Programmiersprachen?
Schreibt einfach hin,
Erfahrungen in Python, Java und Bash
sind erwünscht und gut ist.
Warum nicht einfach
Programmierkenntnisse, ja zum Beispiel
oder sowas?
Bei denen ist da nichts nur
nur Glue-Code.
Bei denen bist du der
DevOps-Superhero.
Du musst sogar Scrum Master
und Coachen und alles dabei machen.
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt,
kann man das so nicht wirklich sagen.
Das ist ja schon alles eigene Sache.
Das ist ja alles schon eigene
Technologien für sich.
Die werden vielleicht am Ende dafür benutzt,
um darüber andere Sachen
wiederum bereitzustellen.
Aber, sagen wir mal so,
irgendwelche Leute, die 8000 Zeilen
Ansible-Playbooks schreiben,
damit man die Sachen besser automatisieren kann,
die irgendwelche
GitHub-Actions bauen,
Cloud-Automatisierung,
vielleicht irgendwelche
Jenkins-Geschichten,
irgendwelche Command-Line-Tools bauen,
dass die Leute besser Sachen
verwenden können, Git-Labs aufsetzen,
was auch immer.
Das kann man ja nicht wirklich sagen,
dass das irgendwie einfach nur
bestehende Sachen zusammenbindet.
Das trifft ja nicht so genau.
Du baust Sachen auf,
die vielleicht dann unter anderem
dazu benutzt werden können,
um bestehende Sachen
besser
zu deployen,
zu testen,
hochverfügbarer zu machen,
wie auch immer.
Zu sagen,
man klebt da einfach nur Sachen zusammen,
trifft es ja nicht so wirklich.
Ja, 10 Minuten habe ich noch.
Wir müssen uns aber hier noch fertig gucken.
Du solltest in der Lage sein,
Moment, hatte dich irgendjemand
noch was anderes geschickt?
Das habe ich hier noch offen.
Ich habe ja noch was.
Ob jemand Skripte schreibt oder Programme,
macht sich schon einen Unterschied.
Wo fängt ein Programm an
und wo hört ein Skript auf?
Ja, man könnte da jetzt
ein bisschen philosophisch darauf antworten
und sagen, ja,
in einem Skript verbindest du ja nur
schon bestehende Sachen
zu etwas Neuem.
Und wenn du was programmierst,
dann baust du quasi...
Aber letztendlich ist der Übergang
so fließend,
dass es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn macht,
das letztendlich zu unterscheiden.
Ja, aber
7LQEAS
schick ruhig trotzdem mal rein.
Und wenn schon würde ich das nicht
anhand der Sprache unterscheiden,
sondern am konkreten Beispiel.
Also wenn ich jetzt
drei Zeilen Bash skripte
und ich da im Prinzip,
keine Ahnung,
CREB von der Logdatei sortieren
und in der Datei schreibe,
wenn ich das verskripte,
dann würde ich auch sagen,
okay, das ist ein Bash-Skript,
aber man kann mit Bash
sicherlich auch so komplexe Sachen bauen,
dass man sagen kann,
ey, das ist eigentlich
kein simples Bash-Skript mehr.
Das heißt, das ist...
Solange du da nicht gute Grenzen ziehen kannst,
macht es aus meiner Sicht keinen Sinn,
es groß zu unterscheiden.
Man sollte einfach sagen,
das sind alles Programmiersprachen und gut ist.
Aber G-Cloud, genau das kannst du ja
mittlerweile auch immer weniger machen.
Ja, du hast so Dinger,
da ist das
als...
da wird das quasi
als Bytecode gemacht.
Manche Programmiersprachen
kannst du sowohl
ahead of time kompilieren,
sowohl in Bytecode ausführen,
sowohl als auch
interpretiert ausführen.
Also kann es ja schon mal
nicht an der eigentlichen
Programmiersprache liegen,
was was ist.
Deswegen, ich finde,
wenn man da versucht,
wieder
was was nicht reinpasst,
das macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Man sollte einfach prinzipiell sagen,
Programmiersprachen und fertig.
Man sollte das gar nicht mehr unterscheiden.
Zumal, wenn schon, überhaupt,
sind alles Programmiersprachen
und Skriptsprachen werden dann
höchstens quasi
ein Teil davon.
Also man könnte sagen,
jede Skriptsprache ist eine
Programmiersprache,
aber nicht jede Programmiersprache
ist eine Programmiersprache.
Sondern man würde einfach sagen,
sind Programmiersprachen fertig aus.
Kubernetes Management in Bash
geboren.
Warum nicht?
Es gibt,
Moment, hier ist ja gar kein
Sourcecode drin, außerdem vor 6 Jahren.
Achso, netcat, ja.
Ok, lass mal kurz gucken.
Ich hab's gerade aufgemacht.
Ich will jetzt erstmal noch mal
diese Sache hier fertig gucken.
Ich merke es dir mal,
Badget, kann das sein?
Badget-Time bei euch.
Bei mir ist auch gleich Badget-Time,
aber das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an.
Also, du solltest in der Lage sein,
Cloud-Ressourcen effektiv zu verwalten
und cloudbasierte Lösungen zu entwickeln.
Ok, passt.
DevOps ist eine Teamarbeit.
Moment, ich denke, ich bin der Einzige,
zumindest hatte ich das bisher so gelesen.
Da solltest du gute Kommunikationsfähigkeit
haben und in der Lage sein,
mit verschiedenen Stakeholdern
wie Entwicklern, Betriebsteams
zu arbeiten.
Bei DevOps super,
du wirst mit komplexen Herausforderungen konfrontiert.
Du hast die Fähigkeit,
kreative Lösungen zu finden.
Ok, alles klar.
Kostenlose Weiterbildung,
umfangreiches Gesundheitsangebot,
Sozialleistung, offene Kommunikation,
spannende Projekte,
Kundenstandorte,
wollen die auch,
dass ich vor Ort Dinge mache,
zeitlich und örtlich flexibles Arbeiten,
Workation, eine Woche im Jahr
als Vorteil so geil.
Sollte das nicht im ureigensten Interesse
des Arbeitgebers liegen,
die Leute ordentlich zu onboarden?
Das ist doch kein Vorteil in dem Sinn.
Das ist Voraussetzung dafür,
dass man den Job ordentlich machen kann.
Regelmäßiges Mitarbeiter-Events.
Boah, Bonkers.
Vergünstigung.
Ok, wir bieten ein Gehalt von mindestens 3200 Euro.
What?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Für den super DevOps-Pfeilpferd,
der alles alleine machen soll.
Das ist ja nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Dafür gibt es sogar einmal...
Nein!
Mal 14, mal 14.
Ok, mal 14, alles klar.
Ja, ist aber trotzdem für den
One-Man-Army-DevOps-Pfeilpferd
sicherlich nicht sonderlich geil.
Ich meine, mal 14 ist es zumindest
noch so, dass,
wenn man die Auswahl hat, das zu machen
oder unter der Brücke zu schlafen,
dann kann man auch das nehmen.
So.
Mein Kumpel, den du mitvermittelt hast,
hat da direkt über 40K,
jetzt fast 50K direkt ab Ausbildung.
Nice.
Da geht aber sicherlich noch mehr.
Ich weiß, dass die gerade richtig
Probleme haben, Leute zu finden.
Je nach konkreter Qualifikation
der Erfahrung ist eine Bereitschaft
zur Überbezahlung gegeben.
Ach ja, das ist aber nett,
dass man ordentlich bezahlt werden kann.
Das ist halt echt nicht so nice.
So, dann gucken wir uns schnell
das hier an.
Schauen wir mal schnell rein.
Was haben wir hier?
IT-Systemadministrator, Senior, Junior.
Was?
Ich gucke jetzt gerade wirklich so.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Oder sind das zwei Stellen?
Die suchen eine Senior-
und eine Junior-Stelle?
Oder heißt das,
die bezahlen dich nur als Junior
und du sollst als Senior arbeiten?
Die suchen einfach nur irgendwas.
Okay, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Spindler.
In Würzburg.
In Würzburg war ich auch
vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit
zu einem
Vorstellungsgespräch.
Aber nicht bei Spindler.
Hä?
Hallo?
Warum kann man hier nicht scrollen?
Was ist das für eine Kackseite, Alter?
Müllseite, Mann.
Was ein Shit.
Alter, die Seite geht nicht richtig.
Okay, also.
Entwickeln Sie die mobile Zukunft.
Bla, bla, bla, bla.
Bla, bla.
Umgang, Team Spirit, Professionalität,
Gemeinschaft, Können.
Bla, bla, bla, bla.
Also, Ihre Aufgaben.
Eigenverantwortlicher Betrieb
der Informationstechnik im Unternehmen.
Mehr generic könnte der Satz aber nicht sein,
was man macht als Admin, oder?
Keine Details zu was?
Ich meine, das ist so...
Das ist so...
Das ist wie wenn man zu einem Schreiner sagt,
ja, eigenverantwortlicher Umgang mit Holz.
Dann sagt der auch, ja, okay,
und was willst du genau von mir?
Sicherstellung und Optimierung
der laufenden Verfügbarkeit unserer Systeme,
selbstständige Fehleranalyse, Behebung,
Backup-Management, Notfallplanung.
Okay, ja, Admin-Kram.
Administration der ganzheitlichen Systemumgebung
inklusive Server-Administration,
vorwiegend Windows.
Oh Gott!
Wahrscheinlich sind das legit alle Leute,
die dort arbeiten.
Projektmanagement für Infrastruktur.
Ja, gut, jetzt ist aber mal langsam gut.
Ja, jetzt ist aber mal gut.
Also, ich meine, da gehe ich ja noch mit,
mit den ersten zwei.
Dass man sich einfach um alles, was es gibt,
kümmern soll.
Ja, also bei den ersten drei gehe ich ja noch...
700 Mitarbeiter?
Ja, dann ist die Stelle,
dann ist das echt nicht gut geschrieben.
Ich dachte, das ist so ein Zehn-Mann-Auto-Haus
oder sowas.
Bei 700 Mitarbeitern braucht man doch keinen ITler,
der einfach alles macht.
Da brauchst du Leute,
weil vor allem auch die IT-Infrastruktur
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen größer ist.
Leute, die sich gut auskennen in speziellen Bereichen
und das dann verstärken und nicht einfach alles,
die alles machen und von nichts richtig eine Ahnung haben.
Also, sagen wir mal so,
hier könnte ich so weit noch mitgehen,
wenn es eine kleine, so Zehn-Mann-Klitsche ist,
die, ja, zwei Admins vielleicht hat
oder eins, zwei Admins hat
und die alles machen müssen.
Aber das ist natürlich dann schon komplett
außerhalb des Scopes,
wie man das so schreibt.
Projektmanagement für Infrastrukturprojekte.
Ganz ehrlich,
du kannst doch nicht das hier alles machen
und nebenbei, ja, ich bin auch noch mal kurz
Projektmanagement...
Ich weiß, was sie damit sagen wollen.
Wahrscheinlich meinen sie das auch gar nicht,
so wie es da steht,
sondern wahrscheinlich meinen sie das in der Richtung,
hey, es muss mal hier
diese neue Software ausprobiert werden,
guckt mal, dass ihr das ausprobiert
und dann installiert so.
Ja, das sind für die Projekte.
Aber so wie das geschrieben ist,
es klingt wahrscheinlich mehr,
als es letztendlich ist,
aber ich finde es trotzdem nicht gut,
dass es so drinnen steht,
weil das sollte wirklich nicht die Aufgabe
von einem Admin sein,
neben diesem ganzen Kram noch Projektmanagement zu machen.
Erstellung und Pflege technischer Dokumentation.
Tja, leider.
Wo wir wieder bei meinem Thema sind,
ja, das ist okay.
Ihr Profil.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossene spezifische IT-Ausbildung,
ein Studium im Bereich der Informatik
oder vermehr...
Ja, alles klar.
Mehrjährige Berufspraxis in den gängigen...
Da müssen sie sich mal entscheiden,
ob sie einen Junior oder einen Senior wollen.
Wenn sie den Junior wollen,
dann wollen sie...
Sie wollen einfach irgendwas, glaube ich.
Mehrjährige Praxis...
Berufspraxis in den gängigen Hardware-Landschaften
mit Betriebssystem
oder mit Betriebsumgebung
vorwiegend im Umfeld Microsoft und VMware.
Hätte ich mal schon so keinen Bock drauf,
vor allem, weil es Microsoft ist.
Kompetenz in der Projektdurchführung.
Das passt so gar nicht dazu, irgendwie.
Das passt so überhaupt nicht
zu der restlichen ganze Projektgeschichte.
Dafür nimmst du einen Projektmanager.
Der muss keine große Ahnung
von Microsoft und VMware haben.
Der muss Ahnung davon haben,
wie man Projekte managt.
Das passt nicht.
Es ist selten so,
und müssen sie auch nicht sein.
Erfahrung mit den gängigen Netzwerktechnologien.
Routing, Switching, Wireless, MPLS.
Sollte das nicht MPLS Tunneling in einem heißen?
Egal.
MPLS Tunneling QoS.
Erste Berührungspunkte mit Azure und Office 365.
Wir wünschen ein hohes Maß an Eigeninitiative.
Proaktive Arbeitsweise, gute...
Ja, also...
Wir bieten...
Festanstellung mit attraktivem Gehalt.
Sagen alle.
Wird halt mal interessieren, wie viel da rumkommt.
In agilen Experten-Teams.
Da hat man auch agil reingeschrieben,
einfach weil es gerade hip ist, verbute ich mal.
Eine moderne Arbeitsumgebung,
mobiles Arbeiten,
Zusammenarbeit mit namhaften Partnern.
Das ist doch kein Vorteil für mich.
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge,
Mitarbeiter-Car-Leasing kann ganz nice sein.
Eine strukturierte Einarbeitung.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich finde, das ist auch kein Vorteil für mich.
Das sollte eigentlich im...
Ureigensten Interesse des Arbeitgebers liegen,
sowas zu machen.
Mitarbeiter-Vorteile, exklusive Gewinnspiele.
Kannst auch eine Gehaltserhöhung gewinnen.
Ja.
Ja, ich finde die Stellenanzeige jetzt nicht so nice,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich finde Projektplanung
und krasses technisches Know-how
passt so irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Zumal du nicht...
Zumal du wirklich alles können kannst.
Von Client bis Server,
bis Cloud,
bis Mobile,
Firewall, Netzwerk.
Was wäre aus deiner Sicht
ein angemessenes Gehalt für die Stelle?
Das fällt mir immer sehr schwer ein,
zu sagen,
weil ich die Stelle nicht stimmig finde
von dem, was sie suchen.
Also, das ist so eine Stelle,
wo ich denke,
die sollte in der Beschreibung
gar nicht existieren.
Deswegen kann ich dafür jetzt auch
diese ganze Projektmanagement-Geschichte
rausnehmen.
Geht es ja irgendwo in Ordnung.
Auch wenn es halt echt ein bisschen viel ist
hier alles auf einmal.
Gerade wenn das stimmt,
was jemand geschrieben hat,
die hätten irgendwie 700 Mitarbeiter.
700 Mitarbeiter,
die werden ja nicht in einer
1-2-Mann-IT-Abteilung-Team haben.
Und dann brauchst du eigentlich wirklich Leute,
die sich schon im Detail damit auskennen.
Du brauchst keinen Typ,
der Windows,
Netzwerk und Firewalls auskennt zum Beispiel.
Du brauchst 1-2,
die sich richtig gut mit Virtualisierung auskennen.
Du brauchst welche,
die sich richtig gut mit Windows auskennen.
Das ist eigentlich das, was du brauchst,
weil du hast ja dann dementsprechend auch
Komplexität,
gewisse Anforderungen
an deine ganze Systemlandschaft.
Weil wenn da 700 Leute dranhängen,
dann ist es halt kacke,
wenn mal was nicht geht.
Hast du eine Musik?
Ich weiß nicht,
keine Ahnung,
wie gesagt,
ich bin da mal an die Stelle,
in dieser Kombination
sollte es so eigentlich gar nicht geben.
Also Gehaltsgefüge Würzburg,
kann ich dir nur sagen,
wo ich mich,
wo ich dort,
oder wo wir da Sachen besprochen haben,
das war über 70k.
Das war so irgendwie,
ich glaub 76k oder sowas.
Mehr wollten sie nicht.
Was mich auch davon abgehalten hat,
weil ansonsten fand ich die ganz nice.
Kannst du die leaken?
Nö.
Bist du im jetzigen Job über 100k?
Ja.
Du kannst dir auf YouTube angucken.
Ich hab das erzählt,
was ich aktuell verdiene.
Musst bei mir auf den YouTube Channel gucken.
Scrollst du ein bisschen durch,
das sollte aus dem Samtnennen
und dem Videotitel direkt hervorgehen.
Irgendwas Gehaltsupdate 2023 oder sowas.
Ja.
Aber wohlgemerkt,
genießt das noch mit einer kleinen Portion Skepsis.
Ich hab das hochgerechnet
in dem Video
mit Bonus.
So geht YouTube Content.
Und mit Bonus,
so wie er aus meiner Sicht realistisch ist.
Ja.
Aber gucken, ich weiß es nächstes Jahr,
ob das wirklich stimmt.
Aber ich rechne ehrlich gesagt damit,
weil ich sehe ja jetzt schon in den Monatsabrechnungen,
was es so gibt.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Ich muss pennen.
Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns morgen, CU.